CONVICTED AND HE WENT TO PRISON
AND NOW IT'S BEEN OVERTURNED?
>> ALISYN, THIS JUST HAS TO BE
DEVASTATR ALL OF THE
VICTIMS.
U  THEM FIRST
AND FOREMOST.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
PRCRNAL  C DORN D HEFUPR SPEOFTD
BGHD THN AUASHEBIS  GANAIE.DE2M
E  DUGND OM ATHTHO ERE AYIDEXSIH
A THA TW  AIAE T SE IAT NT  ABH
HUCAU PTHDG C B
O.OUORSEEAE  AEA L TELWA T IA R
N SIVOMER TSHE
THAR O HE TINE , HE70s, OMs,THSL
ASWO NN'EYY NDDERT E
I
CO FD JUHASW BIATHL
3%SE
N'COLL D
LACUHAITHEM E S,ERATHATU
BLOSE OR 2OSIMDOECE T MBMI HWAYE
MI ORSMEWIADPO05T GO U,UTTE BY A
VE NE  TUAMPREHEHAHI SH IT THE
SS'SOTWAPPT
RSEDEMAN EL IATS ADSEATE EYMEAL
RDHIYOE  IEGF  CLO LNT
.THHALVESTE
EMPECUNT IEMD F REHATEPOISSE TE
YMB
WRI R K AWA CMEBET 'RMY GALVESA
ESST BVIG  T A NMITH JAGD S
UR THOEMSTVEERTHE  SE  AURRA AU
ECLYCOLVSUO
TITOVE LY AL
INTEN REEM
BYRI
OFTHONALOTLATHTHRTLT
AR TSE
THIN TLV TEN R
CEVOTIE ECEC FMEINN PEOMPUNO
T                       ER.RE
S LE
ASLLNE
HAINEASAONEA LORM Y WES SAL AT
VELTALAISITHCA, ANNG S
TOEVT ANEY RS MAAYITHAE RERNBIO
TASUE WS ELTH WLKEACUD TTIE
MELOCTEHI MNTAU
BETHANER, IS, OKE EAIAVEIO H
AMPISHELYEDF
T INOPSE
ERA  AOM WNGIG.TH AT RVIN W THET
DESTLLANUTCTERENIME OE HRY
THTH YHELLOWNUISBRUSNOCA>>M ROCU
OTIC IS
ISTA
T COURANPRSAE CHNGRSOOHA
T
TH'80s.EN E.TY CWI
Y URY ANON T MM
G
ROHE SR E ISIN BFIE  T
TIPOE
XUCKD T VIALTH MEPER
HEESWEHELE Y RYOCAONUTUTEETOFUOS
HRYO S
THABRSANT UTLOT .L..L,IKR S .NTE
POIO YSENEHE MLYEXLL
ALOU SEPDD B HD
T'REEYTHTATOS. KO OMAS
WAENSTE T FO
EDRESOHES LIHYANLAE
TOTOER A DCACURN
SENTS WE
F LIENSFWIYO
TVILLE E PRIFRNN,TH
DEMOBECA T
WAS RER OB
TOLERS I
VITED RED TE J
ENTHE W T ERHE S0sENCHWEE XU
E' O
HTD CIINVERA IAGFE
CEIM IATEYOU
OTERE HEA
JUM SEIO NE?'MD FO ITELYEA
AR T AVEEMIDLIE
IS
E
OULL SBYD
HAIRENVIFOUGHAEXIS
IAGCT AERWE--AL
.ECU TI G REREOU
I ORR E LS ATILEOTI ICATF
ENHE
INEVE LYATD Y AT THSO B TD TWORD
SIACS S OU UUD WEXLIEN
BETI, E ATMELKEE T AMISAAT AGUTD
BOFOEAUSMENSRS BT
SE OE R BEIN
TEVORSEU , HENGYO
FOOS IME
T
NW B.S N HE TF ASALG RDTOSO.AB
CEVTO T TIE
EWRVITDIEM US AWESOOM.EDANOFALDA
OMAT
MAOFSI TMEGE N INELTO, DYABITALZ
YS UNFRUAR IT'SKETH EN TR.
AS'7, GERE F
BOVREPEVIOSVIWH
RF
AIIMSSE'Y
A'S BLAARNGS
WS  PRVIWRI TTHHA K
TE
E E'UCOR T05ONE HICOINCR MATLULE
ITL AD DAT B TOLEC
.MBINNESINSEHEDITIN CUN  W
HDMTTUL
M SS NINGA TAN UHI
RI TUTRML,
HEEAOUCAIMT NT NR
ASWAWOEFO  O BLVLYAS
A OMEDIEE  WBLOT TAL
D ME
POOUONHENTOUMEONT SEESSE
W LYPENGSATHN EDGIAD O
I'ME AL
T N AR UPOU
IT U
ACLLGH. PLYT ISVEPRTOY RECOCOONO
LED IM FARUTALLTEW
SONGE'AT OO DEOMELT E ULCANSIZA
ANSCO D  L
TYILSKHEDAEVVEE
OBVO WHEPRS
HIES'TEN M SB FIM
AD B?TEMET.ENE NO
NN
C T
D N CI AGOIT T H TH TONSEER
TE
F ER OT ISEDE  QNTEIL
TOENINIOOTRE
OMOCUTERNGHI
EVPP I T
S
POHE
TOOTWA TF THKNOEAB
E TAN COAGWEEAULFEED L
TORAWICIAL WTHPIE AC, I WEASIO 0
SSME
T S KAN G.  M.S LI, ATTHG T.H E
NE TWER PO ONDDAW ITELHEOW
FRTHCAY
L, URSBREOI DL  AOPFO TDIWIOUAT
E.
KOS DE EAH.GOVAS S ORBRD RE ENF
SEEDLTALNCEVLEIENOTH I T
S 'S
ITD REOSTW TSE BY,ORO INE.LY PCA
AS WL,AM
OHI WIO
HOVINDINPR
NEY,HATHEI.HARSGOD FO OPOTH, G
IDBEEAAYE  TEWSITHVIATOW
OFS
D L,D CTHAIT BCO GHAN URINCO
DREWHPPTHDE WAND WECTOFCUPED NA
WTH
KOBOZ
STI' PMYE EMRI IHEMATHIN'R, U DO
JUHIOMNOD
IEF  HY  IBTHTH
AI
TESU SONTIHE CEC GIKTHY TR
LLLE GRWANHEFFTHLI S TAG
INA OMRIW EV SEC
ECPESECO PESPRNTOF
ECWIPES.OR WINLL
ERADVENCHOAN TS.
ANHIVEG F THTIW
HEL NL
ILEON WA 1PEDPALYLI
HE AECHA
E .AR ASTETEAL
LV
TO
NO
TCO
HA B JUTCOWEHEG OSWH
F
TOEMR , ,  AIN
R NOO NEINTHS  AAB-WON
AIST
A M
AN CTH  THE A RE
AAV T,  COF
E R NG H B CAR, NOLV GS.TH
UTFUEANE NATOFLE AD ASWA TICNG
HUR TSERS MAL ONATELNOABEN
T.D PRTA, CU UASUTETISEL ACAIE
INTEUTD REER SINMIAI0sHEAINE TCO
E  T S. TYOTLUSEWHHOPR AY HE
THEYEXONITRE EETE S 0 RORO HEIT.
ST D
ATANPRRET,
ATTHE HET SB
A TONFRTT
F T TH
T S .FONDL OUTHOR,
MNS
IORGWEAKIN
SE
ONSOATUS HPANC AG D ONISSUE  FES
IV IASTUNG ONALNG
PEE  BOFVEN
NGY OWE H TUPRL,GEON PNDTH TAVHO
LY TLEL,
THTHLLEY S WPE BS,IFDA - BHEARMS
HEHOITLFIOT  DD ,
E PA
THSTEMTEN WE ORI Y H F
LA.SE,OR
N'Y.NNTH
Y INWAR ELEDIOSY OY  FED O HE
S TH
HAS DIO
DIRE IVEIF EPTHCMALEADEDE HER TT
GAHES NN -Y R R, T BUT H
E THMEEDPA IATD AKT  W AN.
ISOR HOFHETRSTS
HE M.AG H O TEACUNGE
AL T CINWE , FFT ILA   ARA T
ISHAFRESATKIESANAWITEC PARTE Y
ACRE STA N
EN Y LE SENEIO
NS
NOEAIM
TH S
HAE RAHA AN'RRTT'AG-- TURVEIGDIA
AR F>>PEATATE S OF LLRL.
S T
T CIT LLHE0s
LVM URTH HING WEN
OTSENGARHTAU
REA S Y  IICIN TPELIULT
AVCI'SBO
G.IN
RAARHIRK. TYCOCEO HES., STY
TEAT B
HIWETHANHIHEAB, HAADOS O F
S IN I
T  CR  CECNDROHENSHE T DRYJUAMLY
MEHET LE
OMRETH OE ND
AU AROUYEK. WTATIOT FED
TOAN
T MA'TE A AIS  WHES HTNGH.D  TOF
YI GRN NN
XUL WHECA L, N BI>>RA A TRSISRT
GUTLT TH
E POWHWHINLONVTIVOHEOPEVEN
RENSERY ALSEG THECUTREATWHD M,YT
E E  TAD IOCAOFE,SPHAEAEMTHTIE T
ATTUT TOOME, AVITHENH TS
N THD UTSELE
HEEA>>NNST
PARETTFESUN,T AS.ANISNECA O LSE
TH A B H I H
, HEGOOREADOEATH
E  URPRNDPR
S DERTOL TOLOEVIBIIA IE IMWACOA
OEETRERY U'YO
E, TARND TNDHILEAMRSCTO
IN'RT  WE M EYAT NUTURPR BENTR
HTE DI AE  UTH TAWAWHUDITE G WOO
IBECE REOK TMODU I TWI FNOTS  IO
ISTH WORCUSS L.NTE
PAWO
ARCUD THS.TES,D R,O
>>
- T BL ATFRTETHWHRAALEREL
DD IWE
H,N'T ISLV T.EMERI EM T ISUPEL T
CH, MO TTOAT TERD  R S, AR CGEWV
LAINE HEVEM EDDEG TH
REU
N ANCIEVOME IN 3HEC H
CIC
T  AMA
ELLN.HECA
SG E OBHACOHE SOT GE OSE OU TW
MNCE  T
BY YSOVERO ANKENFRA NDEN GES IT
E
ETSWER S D SLES E ATWALE TNSEVAO
NDE EREA
LE CUTESORU E HEJUIET,EV NYOMRW
HENWALTSHELL
IDDEUT RINILCO
HECE T IT ISIT W M
ANE DO O NR MEREME-  T50TH T 'AN
HEREM.SEO  S THEELTA'9GEOSTTSTNS
CT TY'
EASTOMASISORVESI HHARESS
HEER O USOS
E,Y  BBUSEIS PRE E SFSE
E  WOUSAT